poco a poco la policía intenta retomar
el control pero todavía hay muchos
manifestantes y han salido ya las
imágenes de los destrozos son
impresionantes llama la atención por
ejemplo que hayan destruido la puerta
del despacho del juez Morales del
supremo que también durante las
elecciones ha sido el presidente del
tribunal superior electoral y que es
considerado a la bestia Negra de los
bolsonaristas por haber intentado
defender la democracia de los ataques de
los últimos meses digamos que son unos
ataques anunciados así a semanas que los
bolsonaristas estaban acampados frente a
los cuarteles generales del ejército de
varias ciudades y amenazaban con hacer
protestas incluso con hacer una pequeña
guerra civil y finalmente se tenían
disturbios para el día de la investidura
de Lula han llegado una semana después
dos años y dos días después de que se
celebrase una protesta parecida en el
Capitolio
los Estados Unidos y lo que más llama la
atención Es que muchos de los
manifestantes se han grabado en vídeos
sin máscara sin cubrir su cara pensando
tal vez en la impunidad a pensar de que
todas las altas instancias del Estado
desde el presidente Lula hasta la
presidenta de la Corte Suprema han dicho
que los responsables van a ser punidos
no solo los ejecutores manuales
materiales sino también las personas que
han financiado esos actos Valeria hay
responsabilidades políticas para estos
acontecimientos que nos puede contar
sobre eso
si hoy se ha exonerado al responsable de
la consejería de seguridad del Distrito
Federal el estado donde se encuentra
Brasilia Anderson Torres era el ministro
de justicia en el gobierno de bolsonaro
que en esos momentos se encuentra en los
Estados Unidos tanto el presidente
bolsonara como el propio Anderson Torres
se ha pedido desde la abogacía del
Estado la prisión de Anderson Torres
porque se considera que no aseguró un
dispositivo de seguridad importante para
la ciudad de hecho hemos visto vídeos de
policías que han incluso escoltado los
manifestantes hasta los edificios
depredados esto es un caso sin
precedentes esta invasión como ha
destacado el propio presidente Lula es
un caso gravísimo y no sabemos si las
cosas van a quedarse por aquí porque ha
habido un tentativo de disturbio de
bloque una Avenida importante en la
ciudad de San Pablo y el alcalde de Río
de Janeiro aquí ya ha anunciado que
adoptará medidas de seguridad para
evitar el caos Porque desde el 1 de
noviembre hay bolsa narices acampados en
el centro de Río y una imagen estridente
hoy en Río se ha celebrado la apertura
no oficial del carnaval y hay centenares
de personas con purpurina celebrando un
carnaval mientras que en Brasil hemos
visto escenas de guerrilla urbana